and tonight florida republicans they are
following through on their promises
tonight as the state senate in florida
passed a new bill to strip disney of its
self-governing status after the
company's lies and smears against the
state's new parental rights and
education law the bill now moves to the
florida house governor ron desantis
added that he doesn't support
special privileges just because the
company is big and powerful ask yourself
why should disney enjoy special and
generous status especially when they
continue to amplify lies attack
conservatives uh anyway here with
reaction former florida attorney general
pam bondi along with the one and only
fox news contributor leo 2.0 terrell all
right so this just dissolves the special
self-governing status given to disney
over 50 years ago pam you're from
florida why did they all right so they
got it in the first place
why wasn't it stripped a long time ago
why did they get something that nobody
else gets in the state exactly sean you
know they managed to basically fly under
the radar for a very long time this was
established 55 years ago when the
counties where disney was built didn't
have the resources to really help them
so they got all these special
entitlements that they've continued to
hold on to them for 55 years i spoke to
wilton simpson tonight our great senate
president a good friend of mine and he
will be our next agricultural
commissioner of florida and wilton you
know wilton made a really good point he
said the parental rights law in florida
it's about protecting children and
parents rights from not having
five six seven and eight-year-olds talk
to about sex period that's what it's
about protecting what parents want in
the state of florida and disney chose to
wade in to the political debate and now
they're in it and they're are in it and
they're not going to get out of it and
big mistake on their part because
they're about to get all of their
special entitlements taken away pass the
senate we'll pass the house on final
reading tomorrow and ron desantis is
going to sign that law
leo 2.0 terrell will disney claim that
this is a constitutional uh free speech
issue and they're being penalized for it
or
will the state's argument that you don't
deserve
special status went out
i'll tell you right now and pam
summarized disney's position disney free
speech is out there out in the open they
lied about this bill this was a parental
right bill the mouse has been caught and
therefore before the state legislature
has the right to grant this legislation
to strike away to strike away their
special privileges let's be very clear
juan desantis in the floor of the state
legislature they have a backbone and
they're basically sending a message to
all these war corporations that you
cannot dictate policy to the people of
florida i am very very proud of the
state of florida because they are
basically sending a signal to all these
corporations and ginsake those crocodile
tears just absolutely lying about the
nature of this bill final point i was a
school teacher i still have my license
and pam is spot on this is a bill to
protect parents rights over their own
children not for the state and not for
disney to control or indoctrinate
children we have about 45 seconds pam do
you believe that disney will challenge
this in the courts and if they do what
will the result be
they may challenge it they will not be
successful they will not be successful
disney chose to wade into this debate
these liberal elitists instead of
staying in their lane which is what
entertaining families
making a lot of money for their
shareholders but instead they decided to
attack the state of florida they're the
ones who said we're gonna we're gonna
fight this law we're gonna get this law
overturned so they picked this fight and
they're gonna lose this fight sean
it's just to me it's just like the nfl
stay out of politics yeah people of all
backgrounds all
you know everybody there with a shared
passion everybody there with a shared
passion to have a magical day and you
got to ruin it with politics when people
should be having fun not a smart
decision business-wise on their part my
view uh thank you both pam bondi leo 2.0
terrell hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else